all right breaking news tonight the
latest hail mary from the january 6
committee comes in the form of a
subpoena a former trump white house
counsel pat sipoloni now the move is so
desperate
even the new york times sees the
futility in this
saying the move sent a clear signal of
the aggressive tactics the panel is
willing to use to try to force
cooperation of even the white house's
former top lawyer who will most likely
be able to invoke attorney-client
privilege in response to many questions
so joining me now is matt whitaker
former u.s attorney former acting
attorney general under president trump
matt everybody knows that pat is one of
my close friends so i'm going to
disclose that but what does this tell
you about how the committee is really
feeling about the strength of its
so-called case well they keep trying to
entice everyone with this is the most
important thing you could watch and then
when you see what they have you're like
this doesn't tell me anything this i
mean i'm concerned that this crosses a
line of of really peeking into
the most confidential communications at
the white house i mean they already
obviously tried to go against mark
meadows tried to hold in contempt tried
to prosecute him doj said we're not
going to prosecute our chief of staff uh
and now we're going after the white
house council this is uh you know the
constitution is designed for
accommodation and for this interesting
dance between the legislation
legislative branch and the executive
branch this knocks it all down and i
think is really an aggressive and
unnecessary step well in their in their
accompanying letter they basically said
the need for the information
outweighs any concern about the
separation of powers here in this case i
guess it would be executive privilege
yeah but it doesn't that doesn't i mean
that that overstates the case obviously
the president needs confidential advice
from his chief of staff and from his
white house counsel at a minimum uh and
this how do you operate as president if
you're going to be hauled before a
committee at any time when the democrats
get in power how do you operate they
don't want them to be able to operate
don't you think that's what this is
really all about well so they don't want
trump to operate as president i mean
this has been obvious ever since they
took control in january of 2019 and i
went up and testified and sort of put
them you know back in their place but
you know in all honesty you know this is
a step that they will rue the day if
they were able to knock this down if i
were they i wouldn't want to i wouldn't
want to call pat simpoloni up there all
right matt back in august of 2020 a
federal appeals court ruled that house
democrats could sue to force president
trump's former white house counsel don
mcgann to comply with at the time was a
congressional subpoena saying that the
house has a long-standing right to
compel government officials to testify
and produce documents but this is from
trump's impeachment this is the
follow-on to whether you whether he
obstructed justice in the impeachment
thing does that provide any precedent
for them calling i don't think it does
and in fact if you read that opinion the
court really anchors its sort of opinion
in the fact that this was a impeachment
and this was very grave and important
this right now we're in a special
oversight at best i mean one-sided you
know sort of no ability to cross-examine
witnesses
type uh operation i just i don't think
that a court is gonna hold that this is
as important as an impeachment and so
therefore i think it's going to be less
but you know if pat cipollone is smart i
mean he's going to hold his confidences
obviously he told the president a lot of
things and there's no uh i think
competing interest that's as powerful as
the need for confidential attorney
client privileged communications as you
would see you know that in this
committee trying to find out whether he
lunged over a driver and grabbed the
steering wheel um well some colorful
language perhaps being used by the in
the white house but has that has that
never been done before imagine
if you read that nick listen to the
nixon tapes i think yeah all right matt
great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else